when you guys do the six nine [ __ ] it's
crazy because nobody would interview six
nine
we we turned down interviewing him and i
feel like he really just came to l.a and
just tapped in with like the youtubers
yeah but i think you guys have like the
first thing that came out at least it
felt like it but like pretty big what
was the uh
how did give us the back story on how 69
ended up doing his i'm
did his team reach out to you guys or
how'd that go
i can't even remember what happened
there
i think it was
i think they reach out to us honestly i
can't even talk on it i really don't
know
i can't remember but uh but they were
honestly like they were
everyone was cool they were chill like
were you guys worried about any like
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] because you know
he's i was wearing mural for dinner like
so we were in new york
and you went to you went to dinner with
him in new york yeah
we filmed them like a few times and like
i know like
so we go to this like rooftop and we're
all drinking and [ __ ] and uh
and like i was the only one that was
sober and like everyone was getting
pretty sloshed and then i was kind of
like
dude like we're just like on a [ __ ]
balcony like an open balcony
in new york in new york where he
snitched on everybody yeah when all the
shit's popping off and i don't follow
all that stuff so i don't really know i
just know
like a little bit but i was like a
little like [ __ ] like
people are posting stories like [ __ ] if
someone wants to do something right now
they probably could so i was i was
definitely sketching about it but
jeez i'll turn down fine